[Music]
okay so uh i've held the pixel six
let's talk about it
all right so today we get a bunch of
officially confirmed real details on the
new pixel 6 and pixel 6 pro coming up
this year from google i got some very
brief off-camera hands-on time okay so i
didn't get to shoot any of that
but i have a lot of details and i have
some official images that i can share
with you so let's get into all of it so
like i said there's a pixel 6 and a
pixel 6 pro they're both pretty huge
phones but the pixel 6 pro is a little
bigger around 6.7 inches it has glossy
metal rails instead of matte black rails
and it is slightly curved on the sides
of the screen it's 120 hertz screen
instead of a flat 90 hertz on the
smaller one there's also new camera
hardware across both of them with a
shared primary and ultra wide but
there's also a new 4x telephoto camera
on the pro and they have this horizontal
camera bar across the whole back of the
phone side to side that honestly it
looks better in person than it does with
the renders it kind of reminds me of a
nexus 6p which also had a camera bar go
all the way across the back and you can
actually notice uh the metal rails on
top and bottom of the camera bar are
again glossy on the pro and matte black
on the non-pro both up front will have a
hole punch selfie camera in the middle
and a nearly bezel-less display and of
course both run android 12 with all the
new aesthetics and material u and all
those features so that's nice and that's
exciting and there's a bunch more
details to discuss closer to launch
things like the exact battery size the
screen resolution and of course prices
but the one thing i want to talk about
that's across both of these phones
is the new custom designed silicon that
will be in both of them called google
tensor so this was rumored for a little
bit you know pixel phones for years have
been using a variety of snapdragon chips
from qualcomm whatever's available just
like every other high-end android phone
but it was rumored that brewing in the
background was this white chapel project
of google designing their own silicon to
eventually go into the pixel phone this
turned out to be true so there's a
couple different benefits to this and
it's not even a new idea completely you
know obviously apple designs all the
chips in their iphones but also huawei
makes the kirin chips and samsung makes
exynos chips this is the thing that's
been happening and there's even been
little bits of custom silicon inside
pixel phones before already they had a
custom image signal processor called the
pixel pixel visual core and then pixel
neural core and also the the titan m
security chip but
this entire chip this whole phone being
powered by just a tensor chip
well that's a big deal i i think it's
particularly important for the pixel
line specifically because of how much
google does with software and and that
optimization process
and i think i think we're going to see a
lot of big changes here so let's start
with the biggest i think most obvious
place which is in their cameras so we
all know by now that pixels have had
really good photo quality specifically
for a couple years now and that's
because of their awesome software and
computational photography
but the video quality has always just
been meh like not nothing special pretty
average from the pixel
and so what google showed me on pixel 6
was a
comparison with the pixel 6 and the
iphone 12 and the pixel 5. and of course
this is a very you know handcrafted
tailored comparison to show the best
thing they could do but
they're basically taking all those
computational photography chops
and applying them to video because
tensor enables that now
and it was really impressive what i was
able to see we'll see much more hands-on
demos of course i'm sure very soon but
that's exciting that's the hdr that's
the noise reduction the stabilization
all of that smarts in video now too also
you know pixel cameras have always been
great but
since pixel 2
they've basically been using the same
kind of small at this point sensor
because they've got it so dialed with
their algorithms they can of course
improve the glass and of course the iris
opening every year but generally it's
been the same sensor and i suspect they
were reluctant to change it because why
move to some huge new 50 megapixel
sensor if you don't have the
computational photography chops to back
it up so they've just been sticking with
the same sensor but this year with pixel
6 it is all new sensors big new sensors
and i'm really curious to see what kind
of results we're going to get with
tensor and the image processing on these
big new sensors now another benefit and
the other sort of main pillar one that
google was talking to me about was
speech recognition and basically being
able to do as much of this as possible
on device as efficiently and quickly as
possible beyond the google assistant is
very important to them and i use
assistant all the time so i'm happy to
hear this but yeah just being as
dedicated as possible by literally
giving parts of the tensor chip that
sole purpose
of decoding speech into text and making
things like assistant way faster and
speaking of power
i think battery life is another thing to
keep an eye on with the tensor chip in
pixel six so i don't have official
battery size numbers if i get them from
them i'll put them on the screen here
but the point is do you remember when
the max switched from intel design chips
to apple designed m1 chips and literally
doubled in battery life
that's because of optimization and
efficiency i'm not saying we're going to
get that insane level of games here
they're still both arm based you know
tensor and qualcomm chips already arm
based so same architecture but we are
now approaching the same level of
vertical integration that apple has had
with those macs so maybe it'll be a
little better i think the the
streamlining of power and efficiency
with tensor chips
should make for a better battery
experience but on top of all that now we
got to think about you know android in
general google makes android they can
optimize for everything but also now
they can offer much longer
software updates much longer than other
android phones as of right now
technically you know android phones can
offer software updates as long as
qualcomm also officially supports those
updates so typically you'll get
something like three years which is nice
but now that they control the entire
stack they can optimize android for as
many years as possible and they want to
they want to optimize android for as
long as possible to continue giving you
updates because they want to keep you on
that phone i feel like we've seen this
kind of from the other side from the
iphone apple has made a lot of money
from selling iphones for a really long
time but that slowed down a bit and now
people are keeping their iphones longer
than ever so apple realizes they they
want to make as much money from the
person with that iphone during the life
cycle of that phone is possible so
you've seen them move into services
apple tv apple news all these services
you can buy and pay monthly and then
that iphone that you have for a long
time
will make apple a lot of money so with
the pixel google already makes a
majority of their money from ad services
from things like gmail and google search
and google assistant and so now tensor
just enables them
the ability to guarantee way longer
software updates to keep you using that
device way longer like the iphone now if
you really want to go
uh into the weeds i think this could
also have an effect on pricing at least
internally i don't want to get too crazy
with it but google has had to to bargain
with qualcomm to you know get a certain
price for a certain order size for a
certain number of chips
but then samsung might come along and
place like a way bigger order which
could affect like the supply of certain
ships and the whole supply chain is out
of their control so with tensor it's
it's better for google to have more
control over this
but obviously
uh maybe not obviously but qualcomm
has to bargain with their foundry and
get certain prices and eventually upsell
to oems like google so cutting out that
middleman of qualcomm
can actually save them money and make
the price overall lower especially at
scale and i don't know you know this
might not get passed down to the user at
any point maybe they use those savings
for something else but it's just one
more advantage to this but you know what
actually one more thing i just came to
mind
this could be
the beginning of an
ecosystem-wide
silicon thing for google
you know the same way i keep going back
to apple's example but the same way that
m1 chip we've talked so much about is
basically it's a scaled up version of
the a14
i feel like there could be a scaled up
or scaled down version of tensor in
google's feature maybe a scaled down
version for a pixel watch someday or a
scaled up version for a chromebook or
really any other device or a smart
speaker or something like that or a
smart display
that would just make sense to happen
down the line so
yeah and that also makes sense for
future parody because now you know the
same reason the m1 max have better
webcam quality than any other mac ever
it's because they're using the same
image processing as the iphone so for
all of this i guess what i'm trying to
say here is
the first generation of tensor chip
we're about to see in the pixel it's
going to be really interesting to see
what it unlocks to see how it performs
obviously in regular day-to-day people
are going to benchmark it and all that
fun stuff but to see what type of stuff
it really unlocks for the pixel
now and then in future generations too
so something to keep an eye on if you
want to see uh my full video on android
12 and all the features that are already
coming to the pixel when this phone
comes out later this year i'll link that
below like button if you want to check
it out but that's been it for me just
some quick thoughts on pixel six which
is coming up
coming up along with a bunch of other
stuff if you want to be subscribed to
see that of course you should thanks for
watching
catch you in the next one
peace
[Music]